he's one of the top analysts in the game
with NBC is a two-time Super Bowl
champion courtesy of Vizio right here
he's Rodney Harrison how are you Rodney
hey rich how you doing man I'm no you
got it I will give you the floor what
did you take away from the divisional
playoff weekend the most well you know
two teams that really couldn't handle
the moment I'd take the Indianapolis
Colts stupidly shocked the world and to
beat Kansas City and and they just
couldn't handle the moment really
surprised Andrew Luck and the coats and
all the mistakes and things like that
but I was really impressed with Kansas
City Andy Reid's ability you know in
terms of his play calling and it was
good to see big rare win a game and just
you know everybody's been on big red and
and to be able to meet up with the
Patriots I was really really wasn't
surprised with the Los Angeles chargers
they've been in you know situations
close to this and they haven't been able
to handle the moment just disappointing
because I'm such a big fan of Phillip
Rivers I thought they would have had a
better show yeah so what did the
Patriots do to the chart they deleted
the most complete team supposedly that
we've been talking about so what what
did they do I think I think mentally man
it's just so hard like a lot of times if
you have not beat Tom Brady in the
patriots you don't walk in there with a
lot of confidence like the Miami
Dolphins for whatever reason always feel
like they could beat the Patriots but
you know charges you don't have that
confidence and it just seems like the
Patriots were well rested it almost
looked like the Chargers kind of took
them for granted you know you hear
everything about a Brady's not the same
Gronk can only have one catch a thing he
doesn't look the same and Edelman looks
low and then all of a sudden you get
these guys to weeks of rest and
preparation time now they look like you
know one of the top two teams in the
league or at least in the AFC and I
thought you saw that so I mean and not
to make any excuses but is there any
credence to the idea that the Chargers
were in Denver week 17 and then
back-to-back weeks in the early window
on Sunday when it's 10:00 a.m. in their
West Coast heads oh yeah definitely
definitely I played in the league a long
time and had to make those trips back
before you know West Coast East Coast
and it's tough and when you have a young
team and they felt like they've already
surpassed the expectations sometimes you
can take teams from
sometimes you can get a little bit too
comfortable and sometimes that that
change and that travel it wears you down
you got to understand like these guys
you know a lot of these guys just came
from college they're not used to this
the scrutiny the pressure the
preparation all the things that it takes
and then you give coach Belichick two
weeks and Rob Gronkowski talked about it
hey I got a chance a few days to get
away let my mind free and when you have
that time away man it refreshes you and
remember this is a veteran team they've
had a lot of success over the years so
what is Bill Belichick best you can tell
having played for them having won for
him Rodney Harrison what is he waking up
thinking about as soon as he turns the
page to the Kansas City Chiefs and you
read mahomes etc well he's very familiar
with the team and you know obviously
he's gonna give his team a day off to
rest and kind of just enjoy the victory
but he's already broken a lot of them
down trust me they've they've always do
work ahead so he's looking at the
weapons how to eliminate the big place
to think for the Patriots is they have
two quarterbacks that are playing at a
really high level so they feel like they
can match up he'll take Tyreke Hill away
and Travis Kelce and third down in the
red zone so he'll have some things that
he can kind of you know put in their
matchups and you know Patrick Chong
versus you know Travis Kelce so it's a
lot of different things but they'll be
ready man and trust me I asked the
Chiefs fans when I was down there on
Saturday who would who would you want
and a lot of them said hey I want the
Chargers and as I said why didn't know
why not the Patriots oh man nobody wants
Brady and Belichick so it's gonna be a
fun matchup rich I can't wait to watch
it
yeah I know and it's funny every time
that that I mentioned Bella check to say
somebody like Brian Billick on NFL
Network he jokes he he was yeah he's the
only coach in the history of football
that takes away the one thing that you
do best no other coaches attempt to do
that and his tongue is firmly obviously
planted and chief what about Andy Reid
what do you think he sees in this
Patriots team that he thinks he can
exploit at home with mahomes I think
he's I think it's not even about I don't
think he's even looking at the Patriots
team like that I think it's more about
you know his trust and his ability with
his team and I think you know he has a
script he has a mindset of what his team
wants to do
and that's what they do you know I'm
saying they're obviously they're gonna
make adjustments according to if you
blitz a lot if you play a lot of zone
but Andy Reid is so smart and he's so
confident with this young quarterback
and let me tell you rich this was the
first time I got a chance to see him up
close and personal yeah I didn't realize
a couple things I didn't realize he was
that tall because he looks about six
foot on television he's like 63 and the
kid it's just no mistake bothers him
he's like unfazed by mistakes he's so
mature and so humble and just so dynamic
I've never seen anything like it it's
this is only the second time I said wow
when I watch the quarterback the first
time is when I watch Michael Vick play
is that right so he's Vick and him are
the only wild factors for you
you've watched a lot of quarterbacks
like when you see Michael Vick it come
first coming this league
you said wow didn't you yeah it was part
of the DVD you know Duquette Vick and
you know Dunn Falcons and you didn't see
anybody like that and the only August
I'd throw Aaron Rodgers in there the
ability to uncork a throw across the
body you know that sort of thing
you know Favre on occasion will do that
but I understand what you're saying you
know what I'm saying it's like it's just
every week every year Aaron Rodgers
could actually be put in that category
as well as Brett Favre but you know what
I'm saying this guy has that
generational talent man and just how
humble he is and how he deals with the
media and just everything that he brings
man I his parents did a wonderful job
and I couldn't be prouder just from a
former player watching them yeah I know
and what he represents for Chiefs
Kingdom I mean he's the first drafted
quarterback by the Chiefs to win a
playoff game for the Chiefs who have
never hosted an AFC championship game
until he arrived Rodney Harrison here on
the Rich Eisen show let's quickly turn
to the NFC Rams and Saints your first
blush reaction to that NFC Championship
matchup is what
can the saint economics are akin to Rams
defense keep it up it's all how they
play but they're gonna be facing a
different quarterback they're not gonna
be facing back Prescott and that's not a
shot at dak Prescott but you're gonna be
facing Drew Brees and I think the number
one thing that sticks out to me is like
how do you not double-team Michael
Thomas you know this is the guy you know
what I mean it's like I know they do a
good job they hit like I think he had
like nine different receivers but this
is the one guy and it just seemed like
Belichick is the only coach out there
that's average you know I'm gonna take
away the one guy that you don't you know
that we don't want to have success and
it's like other coaches need to follow
that simple format and there's no way if
I'm the defensive coordinator I would
not like let Michael Thomas let light me
up no way it would be Keith Kirkwood it
would be those other guys but it would
not be you know Michael Thomas having a
big day and so the Rams with CJ Anderson
that's it's remarkable how somebody that
gets picked up in week 16 could be such
a difference maker but he's won a Super
Bowl and the ability to keep Gurley
healthy yeah and and rested and then
he's like a battering looks like iron
had Heyward all of a sudden I was so
happy for that kid I'd listen to him in
a postgame interview and he was just he
was fantastic RIT's what listening to
him and just how he you know he got
released from a bunch of different teams
and how he really started coming in at
5:30 in the morning learning the
playbook and just it was a really great
story you know and and the way he's
running and just the level of intensity
and sense of urgency and how physical
and and now you can get a guy that goes
in there and take those extra shots and
where the defense down so when girl he
gets in he's so much faster and it
almost seems like Gurley has another pep
in his step because that you know it's
not all on him that's a lot of pressure
for a young man here in a year out well
Arvind and Maurice jones-drew on game
day morning on Sunday say that Gurley
deep down knows is looking to say hey
how come I'm not inside the 5-yard line
how come I'm out inside the game myself
now well of course from a competitive
standpoint you know you want to be up in
there and you want to you know you want
to score touchdowns but at the end of
the day it's about winning football
games and if it's his time to rest and
chill that's what you do everybody knows
that
girly is the best running back in the
national football league he doesn't have
to go out there and prove it on you know
you know within the 5-yard line but he's
the star running back in at the end of
the day when it matters most he's gonna
be in there well Rodney Harrison you are
here on behalf of Vizio is top value
performer award which recognizes the
players whose on-field performance most
exceeds the value of their contract are
you gonna try and sneak CJ Anderson is
as a late add as a nominee here Rodney
well the nominees are Blake Bart
Martinez Chris Carson Tyler Boyd
Phillip Lindsey and Kenny gala day and
in order to go on and vote you got to go
to Vizio comm slash TV P you can vote up
until January 20th and the fans can
enter for a chance to win their very own
Vizio m-series 70-inch TV and home
theater sound system rich well CJ I mean
you know what I mean can we pound a
table at CJ Anderson with definitely yes
I know you're gonna say Phillip Lindsay
Carson Tyler boy Blake Martinez and
Kimmy but for me I'm going Lindsey
Phillip Lindsay Ashlee I was talking
yeah I said how could you not right I
mean he was incredible yeah just
undrafted free you know and he makes it
to the Pro Bowl and and you know it was
a lot of disappointing parts on that
offense but I mean he was the one bright
spot yeah and Chris Carson was terrific
to tyler Boyd Kenny Galloway Blake
Martinez go again to Vizio dot-com / TVP
to vote for the top value performer
before I let you go Rodney Harrison
you're a prediction who as to who's
gonna play in Atlanta for the Superbowl
would be first blush go I'm gone Saints
you know just its that is the last team
achieves Brady and Belichick but that's
why they info Holmes they trust man they
really believe in himself and about rich
either who does he wanted Rodney before
the season and Chris Brockman my called
my producer sitting out here my compadre
sitting out here can attest correct
Chris Brockman before the season correct
I said Patriots Rams and Rams went at
all that's what I said prior to the
season so I'm sticking with it it's
right now I'm sticking with you Thank
You Rodney you take care of man you're
wrong
that's why you are who you are that's
why you you're doing as well as you are
an NBC and also with the vizio thanks
for joining thank you you bet that's
Rodney Harrison that Rodney underscore
Harrison on Twitter the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience